hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast
Efram liquid biopsy I am Brenda Kelly
Kim of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes the
leading social networking site for
science professionals for more
information please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation properly please click on
the support button at the top right of
your presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an educational web
seminar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
for obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
David Wong DMD dr. Wong is the associate
dean of research and director of the
oral head and neck oncology Research
Center at UCLA in his work at UCLA he
has developed a liquid biopsy technology
electric field induced release and
measurement he firm liquid biopsy it
provides the most accurate detection
that can assist clinical treatment
decisions for the most common subtype of
lung cancer non-small-cell lung cancer
with tki that can extend the disease
progress free survival period for these
patients
ELP can detect CT dma a single copy
level whereas DD PCR detects CT DNA at a
minimum of 10 copy number in addition
ELB requires only 40 no liters of sample
no sample processing reaction time is 15
minutes and can be performed at the
point-of-care or high throughput
reference lab using plasma or saliva I
will now turn it over to dr. Wong for
his present hello everyone I'm David
Wong at the University
you
hello everyone I mean David Wong at the
University of California Los Angeles and
I'm very glad to be sharing with you
today a topic that that's very much in
sync with a emerging landscape of liquid
biopsy and perhaps in this half hour
that we're going to spend together a
uniqueness in this landscape of of
liquid biopsy that's with the technology
that they truly delivered their
performance and and the ability to - to
detect circulating DNA so the the title
of my talk is is he is on this first
slide and and I think we all agree that
it truly echoes the current theme of
precision and personalized medicine the
next slide is a disclosure slide and
I'll try and navigate it here
disclosures slide that I have a virtual
company with University of California
San Julis and I'm also consulting from a
number of entity that you see on screen
so the the President Obama announced
steerer to say of the Union address a
moonshot initiative in in cancer
including a one of the seven initiative
of early cancer detection I want to
highlight some of the the key elements
here utilizing genomic and proteomic
targets and sensitivity of the
technology for detection and the ability
to early detect of detection of cancer
and and finally and certainly
importantly minimal invasiveness I would
like us to anchor all of these these key
points if you will of early cancer
detection and how the essence of my of
my message that I want to share with you
today can echo land into these key
elements for early cancer detection so
the journey that we started was a decade
ago when one of the 27 Institute at the
National Institutes
the installed dental and craniofacial
research initiated a set of initiative
to scientifically credential and
translate oral fluid saliva for clinical
utility and the the variant of that
those initiative is to is to utilize a
non-invasive bio fluid for a disease
detection as well as the opportunity or
the ability to to monitor our health
health as well so so with these
initiative in mind my lay up as well as
others engage in a in a series of
activities that that led to the the the
credentialing if you will of a number of
diagnostic tools that you see on the
slide here they we define the protium
together with with Sudan Fisher and and
John Yates at Scripps and my lab also
further defined a number of of
scientific endeavors that empowers
saliva for for for translational and
clinical utility including extra
cellular RNA the metabolomic microbial
presence that that differentiate itself
in health between gender and upon aging
also at the same time is the is the
opportunity to develop tools if you look
on the on the left here on the left here
is a the button that you can click and
see there are point-of-care tools that
that is envisioned that eventually will
allow clinicians and and and and and
healthcare providers to take a drop of
saliva in in in low resource settings or
whatnot that could allow for permit the
detection of of these disease
discriminatory targets in a non-invasive
bio fluid so the ability to monitor
health early detection of disease this
is our own body and assemble the website
here that you can see a WWE skb we
thermos saliva all makes knowledge base
and is it's it's sort of being being
housed
and assembled in a website at the
University of California Los Angeles and
I welcome you all to have a channel to
take a look at it where are the signs
and and and the credentialing and
foundation any of you well of saliva for
for clinical and translational utility
so so with this thoughts in mind in in
the past three years there is a facet
that engaged into this landscape here
and that's that's the ability to not
only utilize his own mix in firm ation
in saliva to developed if you will a
biomarker for disease detection but also
you know engaging in this landscape a
liquid biopsy so the next slide is is
it's just an introduction or liquid
biopsy and the following slide here
really embodies what liquid biopsy
perhaps in our current understanding
that that parental tumor you know you
know shed
you know cells which constitute the the
the the the the metastasis phenotype and
also a t-cells go through those who sell
their health is shed cc's pathognomonic
if you will fingerprint off of the
mutations that that that's that sort of
may may may be representative if you
will of the parental tumor has
circulating DNA so the ability to obtain
these these are circulating tumor cells
or the circulating tumor DNA through a
bodily fluid is constituting that the
foundation of a liquid biopsy and and it
certainly is compelling as as far as
they and that clinical need to to serve
as a surrogate of of having a tissue
based biopsy so so the ability to do
that clearly is abundantly clear current
technologies of digital PCR you know
next-generation sequencing you know
capturing circulating tumor cell this is
a very intensively being being being
evaluated and being applied in in a
clinical setting what I like to bring to
you know the field and that we have
through this these NIH initiative a core
technology
which we term electric field induced
release and measurement that has the the
characteristics the unique properties
that that has the performance and also
the the operational features that that
really puts it in a very unique in you
know posture in this landscape of U of
liquid biopsy the following slide here
it really is a schema Howie firm are you
know you know work if you will a drop a
bio fluid be it plasma it's librum where
these circulating tumor DNA are
envisioned to be in body within vesicles
you know these extracellular vesicles
and through a electric field that is
rapidly pulsating it will we need to
lead to the release of these circulating
tumor elements into into into the bio
fluid and you can see in the in this
light here these these represent
sequences they may have alteration be a
deletion being mutation and this is then
capture in a microwave format where each
of these wells constitute a environment
where the mutation will be detected a
capture probe that is uniquely designed
to capture new mutation and if if such a
mutated sequence is is hybridized then a
detector probe will come in that will
also harbored I to this complex and this
detector broke has a enzymatic conjugate
that allowed the signal to be detected
via a redox reaction and and rapidly
lead to the the signaling if you will of
the presence or absence of the mutated
sequence and could be quantifiable as
well what perhaps is not not exactly you
know obvious in this law is that this
whole process occur within within
minutes a molecular hybridization
process that is that is in rapid scale
and and also very miniaturizing in
volume we're talking about 40 micro
liters and
and in a rapid pulsation of 50 cycles of
an electric field leading to the
capturing nothing of the on the of the
mutated sequence and the repulsion of
the other nonspecific sequences and then
late to the the registration of the
signals all within within within ten
minutes
so so so so also this whole process it
doesn't require the in the processing of
the bio fluidly there's no extraction of
the nucleic acid is a direct detection
so with that in mind this technology was
put to test and and in in in to blinded
clinical studies that will both have
been studied and this study was was done
in in both done in Asia because the the
indication that we selected for the
proof-of-concept well a study is
non-small cell lung carcinoma it's the
majority form of lung cancer were in
western country 20% would Harbor these
you know you know you know signature
mutation in that you know tyrosine
kinase domain of epidermal growth factor
20% of these patient will have these
these these these signature mutations if
you will which are which are clickable
these are actionable mutations where
where arrest
it could be administered or to these
patients and extending the survival free
period of these patients up to a year or
a year two and a half so so so the
ability to to identify or early detect
these actual mutation in an dossier of
lung cancer patients is is of important
now it importantly is is that while in
it one in the western country 20% of the
patient have this mutation in Asia these
this mutation occur in about 2 to 3
times the frequency so we the to say
that we did was in Asia and the next
slice that really represent the outcome
of one of these two studies and we look
at both plasma as well as saliva from
from from a cohort of patients this is a
blinded randomized study where the the
tissues were genotyped locally at the at
the hospital
in this case here in Taiwan and the
plasma and in saliva were collected
prospectively blinded and randomized
into UCLA four four four four four a
firm determination so what we're looking
at here is the plasmid Adam we have bio
fluid at all these samples before biopsy
pre surgery and after biopsy and each of
these a collection of data points here
on the actual you know data plot as
shown in in in in in in in chart a and B
here before biopsy of of the mutations
in exon 19 deletion and the other is a
point mutation also imitate a domain of
858 the actual data distribution here
what we can see is that in the in the
individual that don't have neither one
of these mutation cluster very tightly
you know at this and this registration
here and the the XOR 19 mutations those
patient that manifests has a
distribution that we can clearly see it
at a higher readout whereas the the the
alternative rotation in this case if 858
these are mutually exclusive mutations
as we know our cluster itself very
similar to to the control samples and
and and and the the chart below
illustrate the the a you see it you know
we're in the curve and and through this
the evaluation here list this pilot
project indicated a very encouraging
area under the curve as you eat as we
see here the other mutations increase in
pre-surgical samples in 858 mutation
exhibit a profile very similar to the XR
19 in the sense that the control samples
are cluster you know in in in and in in
in low registration of the electrical
read out the account in the oddity sort
of the alternative mutation exon 19
register in a level almost are the same
as a control whereas the those patient
that manifests a genuine x
nineteenth deletions as 8:58 I'm sorry
is it being demonstrated here again the
area and the curve is very encouraging
the post-surgical pose biopsy samples
exhibit a profile that is very similar
you know very unique segregation of the
of the of the other positive you know
mutated samples exon nineteen and also
the 858 mutations again the the the
performance curve has being shown on the
bowel here and also very encouraging
with gradient 95 percent accuracy our
sensitivity as we see here so that's the
plasma reader of the cohort of forty
four subjects that were genotype locally
and the plasma and saliva blinded and
sent to UCLA we also looked at saliva
which is which is a a fluid of interest
to us and the following slide
demonstrated that again this is all
utilizing 40 microliters of the bio
fluid without extraction a direct
detection what we see is this Elohim
that I'm pre biopsy close biopsy looking
at exon item deletion 858 mutations the
the readout of the mutated samples in in
in in the pre biopsy is very similar and
has a performance that is very
encouraging as is being illustrated in
the in the in the ROC curve that that we
see below here and and and similar for
the post surgical samples as well and
the illustrator on the right for both
excellent 19 deletion and 858 the
mutated samples are clearly distinctive
all three of the control and and then
the alternative mutations and the same
for a 58 rotation as well so these
outcomes were very encouraging again
this constitutes a blinded randomized
study this study was was published in
you know in November of 2015 and a
second study was recently published
using the cohort you know from from from
mainland China illustrating a
performance that it's very similar to to
what we saw in the
in the data that we we just demonstrated
so so these these outcome you know
prompted us to to evaluate further you
know the mechanistic perhaps you know
underpinning you know of you know in a
disease like like non small cell lung
carcinoma they they did is shuttling of
information from the parental tumor into
body fluids in from from pleural
effusion fluid to plasma and it into
saliva the following few slides are a
very you know you know you know telling
in the sense that you know this is the
circulating you know tumor DNA that a
pathognomonic all the disease like lung
cancer how it's it sort of presents
itself how it shuttled information from
the parental tumor into into into plural
you know cavity and and also into in the
circulation and finally you know into
saliva so so initially we we sort of
build our hypothesis by looking at tumor
cells that I grow in lung tumor cells by
the way that harbor either one of these
mutations and we can see that these
these shedded circulating tumor DNA a
package predominantly in in one of the
three forms of of these extracellular
vesicles namely the the exosomes so so
what we see here is is that in these is
in lung cancer cell going in on a dish
we're harboring the conditioned media we
fractionated into a pop down achmadi
microvesicles and exercise and we then
see the distribution of most of these
mutated sequence either exon nineteen
which is here and also the the the 858
mutations are Harbor in the excess or
mole fractions so these fractions are
further characterized using using these
specific protein cell service targets as
well as morphologically using you know
you know transmission electron
microscopy as well and perhaps what is
what is more telling and and perhaps is
surprising is when we begin to look at
these fractionated
are elements within these fluids the
fluids are pleural effusion fluid which
is proximal to the tumor and plasma and
then saliva them using the current
technology which is the consider to go
standard digital you know droplet PCR
and also our technology of affirm and
what we see is something surprising to
us using digital PCR we see that we can
clearly detect you know in MPE in
mulligan folklore efficient fluid in
plasma of these mutant sequences but not
in saliva okay digital just weren't able
to pick up anything in saliva at all and
whereas you know similar to the the
study that i show you and also another
study that was just just recently
published in firm this technology was
able to pick up you know you know these
mutant sequence in the pleural effusion
fluid in plasma and clearly in since
alive as well with the performance that
that we see here we have a second
generation or ephraim technology where
we saw in the last two studies on the
first generation when you can see the
clean separation of the control signals
clustering you know here whereas the the
the mutated sequence in this case unix
in nineteen it is clearly separated and
and the performance of these of these i
still call them pilot study because the
power is is is it fairly it is it's
fairly small but however a definitive
study is currently in progress with 300
samples that we're we're looking into so
a unique outcome of this of this sort of
you know you know scientific evaluation
of the underpinning is that is that
they're these mutants sequence are
clearly in saliva and the technology
that that that enables this is the
detection is is this electric field
induced release in measurements the
current tools of digital PCR was not
able to to pick that out pursue so we
find it you know very very very very
telling in the sense that that these are
these are clear
you know detectable elements as part of
the circulating tumor you know
environment in saliva but the technology
did that allows visibility or detection
is is affirmed so further to to
understand in my information I have a
performance you know uniqueness or
perhaps even advantage of being able to
to detect these the circulating tumor
DNA in in non small cell lung carcinoma
patients we evaluated the the
sensitivity the typical analytical
performing feature of ephraim comparing
the digital PCR the following few slides
demonstrates you know the the benchmark
comparison as well as some unique
outcome that i want to share with you
looking at the limit of detection okay
and and and we have done this
extensively using digital and using
reference DNA from horizon diagnostic
from the united kingdom as we all know
that using digital PCR there there needs
to be a minimum of five to ten copies in
the reaction volume in order for for
linearity for detection what is of
interest is being shown in this line
here using affirm that the minimum copy
number for detection is is a single
digit is one in as we see here for both
x 119 and four 858 detection perhaps
what is what is surprising is is the
next step that we we went into further
in the evaluating you know why ephraim
has such a performance because the copy
number is i think explains in part but
it doesn't totally in a rational noise
as to as to why ephraim had the
performance that that that that we have
observed in our clinical study so our
hypothesis were tested that that you
know while the common understanding that
circulating to midi and a plasma have a
half a fragment size of about 160 170
base pair
you know we rationalize that the
fragments why is it that that perhaps
any firm can can't be utilized as a
template for detection may have a
difference than the digital PCR NGS in
is requiring
so we took genomic DNA from cell line
that harbored these mutation we shear it
as we see here on left using increasing
cycle of shearing and you see the
average size of these of these cell to
share DNA decreases over over shearing
cycles and the 106 Emily base pair
shearing is about maybe the three to
four sharing and and decreasing in is in
it's in the sizes we see towards the
right and then we muted utilize these
share DNA and then and then use both at
digital PCR to to detect these mutate
mutant sequence and what we see here is
is it on this disk on this chart here on
the right using digital PCR which is
this line here the solid gray line here
the more shear this sample the lesser
the detection signal of of detecting
this sequence by digital PCR okay which
is which is not surprising which is what
we what we would expect now what is
surprising and Thoreau leaks are
surprising is it when affirmed is use to
detect these shear sequences we can see
that in this in this light green line
here a firm not only detect these
sequences and upon the defragmentation
increasing fragmentation of these of
these of these genomic DNA there is a
corresponding increase in signal
detection intensity we we currently why
we were we there can rationalize the the
the the sort of phenomena that underlies
this this this enhanced detection but
this is a reproducible you know outcome
that that there really is is is is is
surprising and perhaps it echoes that
that the value of IV firm in in its
ability detect you know shorter new
nucleic acids of a sequence so so with
that with that in mind and you know the
limit of detection of single copy
detection and then the fragment size you
know could they constitute the rationale
as to my you know recirculated
could could be detectable by by Ephraim
in a in a fluid you can certainly
detecting plasma but in saliva Ephraim
is the technology that does that so so
we're currently in the process of
initiating this further mechanism but
the following slide here is something
that I want to demonstrate to you the
platform that's that sort of enable this
this clinical work is now in place a
colleague of mine together with whether
industrial vendor are creating
point-of-care platform is being shown
here as well as a high throughput
platform that could be eventually in a
reference lab setting this is a 96-well
you know capacity whirr whirr whirr
whirr whirr you know a reference lab or
or high-capacity readout could be could
you know could could be conducted so so
with with all of these sort of
information that I'm presented to you
today I want to sort of represent what
this may deliver as a as a clinical
value or a utility in a clinical setting
in in in the near future
what we envisioned is that as we
understood as we understand that the
current clinical practice in an
individual that are symptomatic a nodule
on a chest film that's that's needs to
go through you know bronchoscopy and
biopsy and then the tissue is being sent
to a reference lab and and then within
within the weeks that information comes
back to the physician and then you know
you know treatment decision could be
implemented in mutation is present then
these TTI inhibitors are the inhibitors
could be prescribed and and and in in a
logical way what we envision that that
capability could be accessible and and
and and available you know at the point
of care where were a bio fluid be it
blood where you need 10 ml of blood or
100 mm
urine and if one were to utilize affirm
that capability translate into a drop of
blood how perhaps you know a drop of
saliva where a collector could be
utilized and then a political unit could
be in the in the physician's office
where information could be deciphered
and detected and available within
minutes and allowing treatment decisions
could be implemented at the point of
care so so so that's the excitement that
we look forward to that perhaps you know
a plant definitive validation of the
technology and the regulatory approval
that this capability that could that
could echo the ability for for
personalized you know medicine and
precision medicine implementation in
that in a point-of-care setting with the
performance you know again I think
diagnostic at the end of days is is
really a a performance you know
parameters were occurring technology as
as we knew that using digital and angeas
for for detecting these these sort of
action mutations the concordance is
about is about seventy percent with
tissue genotyping whereas this
technology that through the pilot study
and we're going through a definitive
evaluation has has a very encouraging
outcome that it's great an idea for 95
percent sensitivity so so with that in
mind and I think the advantages or the
the that we envision that this Ephrem
technology coupling with minimally
invasive maybe in blood or other body
fluid and perhaps you know saliva could
be considered as a viable clinical fluid
it from F cultural preferences
individual preferences minimal volume
you know is required it's it's
cost-effective identifying action-movie
patient's and when you think about these
these patients even though they're on
the Resta within a year you know far
majority of them develop and acquire
resistant mutation which is almost
impossible if one will do a follow-up
biopsy on this individual point occur hi
the reference lab capability and the
ability to know now you get having that
capability and the point of care is it's
important so so on that note I'm glad to
have the opportunity to share this these
outcome with you and the slide here is
for me to acknowledge all the colleagues
in my lab that carried out that work and
my collaborators and importantly the
support particularly through the
National Institute of Health and that
make this possible thank you that's all
the time we have for questions but I
would like to once again thank dr. Wong
for bringing this presentation to us
today today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through October of
2016 you'll receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay and we
invite you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all we have for today
we hope to see you again next time
goodbye